في ثانيه زياره له الى الخارج منذ بدا
الغزو الروسيه الى اوكرانيا قبل حوالي
عامه وصل الرئيس الاوكراني الى لندن في
طريقه الى بروكسل حيث سيشارك في القمه
الاوروبيه غدا في محطته
البريطانيه
على تعهد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
بمواصله دعم اوكرانيا لتتمكن من تحقيق
انتصار حاسم هذا العام الكلام اذا هناك
الذي ذكر امام البرلمان بالعرض البريطاني
لتدريب طيارينا اوكرانيين لكن يريد اكثر
زلينسكي يريد طائرات مقاتله من بريطانيا
ومن الغرب
نحاول الحصول على معلومات اكثر حول خطاب
الرئيس الاوكراني في البرلمان
البريطاني مع انور القاسم مراسلنا في لندن
اهلا بك انور اذا ما ابرز في خطاب امام
البرلمان
يعني حقيقه تركيز كبير جدا على تزويد
القوات الاوكرانيه باسلحه ثقيله ودبابات
وطائرات متقدمه
تستخدمها سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني طبعا
هناك ترحيب كبير بالرجل الذي لم تعلن عن
لم يعلن عن زيارته ووصل مطار ستانستيد حيث
قابله هناك رئيس الوزراء
هو سيكون برنامج هذا اليوم مكثفا جدا اولا
التقى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني وتباحث
وطالب بتزويد اسلحه ثقيله لتحرير الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله وهزيمه الاجتياح
الروسي كما قال بعد الاجتماع الذي انتهى
قبل قليل ايضا هو يتحدث من الزعماء
القليلين عبر العالم الذين يتحدثون امام
البرلمان البريطاني مباشره هناك ترحيب به
بشكل كبير في البرلمان هو يطالب بمساعده
البريطانيين من خلال تقديم اسلحه وعدم
الاكتفاء بما تم تقديمه حتى الان ايضا هو
سيزور قاعه ويست مانستر الشهيره التي كانت
اخر زياره لرئيس الولايات المتحده اوباما
وقابل الملك فيها ثم ايضا
سيزور الملك تشارلز في قصره بحضور مجموعه
كبيره من السياسيين
والمهتمين بعد ذلك سيزور مركز تدريب
القوات
الاوكرانيه في بريطانيا سواء بالنسبه
للعاملين على تسيير دبابات بريطانيه منحت
بريطانيا 14 او 14 دبابه للقوات
الاوكرانيه متطوره جدا تسبق وهي اسرع
ناريا من الدبابات الروسيه ايضا بريطانيا
ستدرب
طيارين اوكرانيين ايضا سيزور هؤلاء جميع
هؤلاء الرئيس الاوكراني قبل
يطير الى بروكسل اذا هي زياره حقيقه تؤكد
على عمق الروابط ما بين اوكرانيا
وبريطانيا وايضا لحذف بريطانيا على زياده
الدعم وعدم الاكتفاء
بما حصل حتى الان شكرا لك انوار القاسم
البرلمان البريطاني